comment expliquer que des personnes
issues d'un milieu social similaire ont
des modes de vie et des goûts similaires
cette question est celle que pierre
bourdieu s'est posé dans son célèbre
ouvrage la distinction ilir formule ce
qui sera l'un des concepts central de
son oeuvre
l'habitus je m'appelle sylvain drame
mais je suis professeur de sciences
sociales dans le secondaire supérieur et
je vous expose dans cette vidéo
l'essentiel du chapitre iii de la
distinction de pierre bourdieu l'habitus
et l'espace des styles de vie dans
l'épisode précédent je vous expliquais
que les agents ont une position sociale
déterminée par la détention d'un volume
de différents capitaux économique
culturel social et symbolique
l'espace social et stratifié en trois
grandes classes classes dominantes la
classe moyenne et la classe populaire
elles mêmes subdivisées en fraction
dominante et dominer selon la structure
des capitaux détenus
si cela n'est pas clair pour vous je
vous renvoie vers cette vidéo qui vous
donnera les bases pour comprendre le
propos du jour à cet espace des
positions sociales qui peut évoluer dans
le temps faut-il le rappeler correspond
un espace des styles de vie pour un
ensemble d'individus situé au même
endroit de l'espace social correspond un
ensemble cohérent de pratiques et de
comportement qui constitue un style de
vie objective à bourdieu ainsi sur le
fait que ce sont non seulement des
attitudes nos si un rapport au monde qui
est lié à chaque position dans l'espace
social structuré par la détention des
capitaux la définition de classe sociale
provient forcément d'une classification
des pratiques des agents mais ces
pratiques sont elle même porteuse de
jugement classificatoire que les agents
font de ces mêmes pratiques et de celle
des autres agents nous sommes ici proche
du coeur du concept de d'habitus de
pierre bourdieu l'habitus et cette
disposition intériorisé à la fois
génératrice de pratiques et système de
classement autrement dit l'habitude
c'est le logiciel que j'ai intégré de
parma socialisation qui fait que je me
comporte d'une certaine manière dans une
certaine situation mais aussi qui fait
que je trouve le comportement des autres
et le mien comme appréciable ou non
l'habitude c'est une structure structuré
puisqu'il produit des comportements
classable est classée donc c'est
structuré et en même temps une structure
structurantes qui classe les pratiques
c'est dans ce double mouvement de
l'habitus que se construit l'espace des
styles de vie si des individus ont des
styles de vie très proche c'est parce
que c'est le même chaîne qui est actif
pour la production et la perception de
ce style mais aussi de celui des autres
autre chaîne d'actions
produit inévitablement d'autres effets
et on voit ici que la coexistence dans
l'espace social et au moins basé sur une
différenciation le modèle théorique de
bourdieu est assez limpide les
conditions d'existence d'un individu
c'est à dire la détention d'un volume et
d'une structure de capitaux produit une
structure structurée et structurante
génératrice de pratiques et de systèmes
de valeurs conduisant à l'adoption d'un
certain style de vie distincts d'autres
styles de vie les classements et les
jugements de valeur que nous opérons
plus ou moins consciemment à l'encontre
d'autres individus sont liés à notre
habitus et se retrouve dans des
qualifications et des classifications
comme s'est distingué ça fait bourges
c'est des trucs de beauce c'est vulgaire
c'est pour les baraques qui n'est
vraiment pas pour moi ce n'est pas mon
style que nous pouvons faire de
certaines pratiques bourdieu et met
d'ailleurs répété que le principe de la
distinction et le dégoût du goût des
autres
rappelant par là le principe structurant
de l'habitus comme système de valeurs
même si nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation totalement inédite
la structure structurée et structurante
de l'habitus nous conduit à adopter un
comportement et une perception cohérente
dans et pour notre classe sociale qui
est socialement compréhensible en dépit
de toute recherche intentionnelle de
notre part nous ne cherchons pas à être
socialement cohérent dans nos pratiques
et pourtant nous le sommes
bourdieu dit que cet habitus produit par
des retraduction contraintes aux champs
dans lesquels nous agissons une harmonie
de pratique commune avec les autres
membres de notre classe l'habitus permet
des transpositions systématique en
fonction des conditions d'actions qui
font que l'on perçoit objectivement d
air de famille entre les comportements
des membres d'une même classe sociale ou
bien comprendre ce qu'est l'habitus ils
font donc s'intéresser à sa genèse
l'habitus est forgée dans le quotidien
de nos vies lui même limité est
conditionnée par la procession où nos
concessions de certaines ressources qui
font que nous intériorise ont certains
réflexes et certaines préférences
par exemple les professeurs possèdent un
assez bon volume de capitaux mais avec
un certain déséquilibre dans leur
structure il possède plus de capitaux
culturel que de capitaux économiques de
cette manière ils développent un certain
rapport à ses tics nous dit bourdieu au
monde c'est à dire qu'ils vont être très
économe et privilégier les consommations
intellectuel plutôt que les
consommations matériel en effet ils
préfèrent consommer des oeuvres d'art
dans les
les expositions ce qui est une pratique
financièrement accessible autant
qu'intellectuellement exigeante que de
se lancer dans des collections privées
personnel d'oeuvres d'art dont ils n'ont
de toute façon pas les moyens leur
avidité culturel et borné par leurs
ressources économiques limitées
développe donc un habitus cohérent avec
cette condition qui sera à la base de
nouveaux comportements homogène
socialement autre exemple les classes
populaires ou un volume de capitaux
faible celui ci ne permet pas d'engager
du personnel de maison et d'acheter des
équipements ménagers onéreux il consacre
donc beaucoup de temps aux tâches
ménagères
dès lors les personnes composant les
classes populaires développe un goût
pour ce qui est fonctionnel pratique du
facile à entretenir et à nettoyer à
l'opposé des classes dominantes qui
privilégie l'esthétique et le style à la
fonction ou à usage
peu importe que tu es l'ustensile ne
soit pas pratique du moment qu'il est
beaucoup dans ces deux cas cette
disposition à l'ascétisme chez les
professeurs à l'usagé et kas populaires
restent actifs dans d'autres contextes
et renforce l'homogénéité des styles de
vie il ya des conséquences
philosophiques à la théorie de beaulieu
c'est une évidence ou une mise en
évidence social de la mort faty ou amour
du destin tels que la formule et
nietzsche les individus aiment ce qu'ils
sont et ce qu'ils ont autant que ce
qu'ils ont et sont ceux qu'ils aiment
car c'est ce qu'ils peuvent être est ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir
pour le dire plus simplement on aime ce
que l'on a et on n'aime pas ce que l'on
peut avoir
on fait ce que l'on peut et on rejette
ce que l'on peut faire on voir étudier
en profondeur l'habitus de chaque
position sociale bourdieu rappelle que
l'on doit prendre en considération
différents éléments en plus de la
logique propres de chacune des positions
et de la distribution voire de
l'opposition des pratiques entre les
positions dans l'espace social
il faut également envisager les
contraintes intrinsèque de chaque champ
l'alimentation ou le sport en tant que
champ sont porteurs de contraintes sur
lesquels les chaînes de l'habitus
viennent se greffer vienne décliner
l'action de chaque agent certains sports
sont par exemple lui prédisposé à être
adoptée par certains groupes de tennis
le golf qui évite les contacts physiques
et requiert un certain style sont
intrinsèquement liés aux classes
dominantes dont l'habitus porte à
privilégier le style à la force purement
physique cette dernière plus conforme à
l'habitude ce des classes populaires et
consacrée dans des sports comme la boxe
ou le
tourisme cependant il ne faut pas en
arriver à considérer qu'un sport ou une
pratique alimentaire est par essence
fait pour telle ou telle classe sociale
tout est question d'appropriation et de
retraduction sport très physique le
rugby est à l'origine un jeu populaire
qui est codifié moraliser par les écoles
d'élites anglaise au 19e siècle elles
traduisent une pratique de manière plus
conforme à l'habitude de classe en y
intégrant des éléments abstraits comme
le fair play est une définition précise
et minutieuse des règles du jeu de plus
certaines pratiques peuvent en leur sein
faire l'objet de certaines singularité
sociale le rugby est ensuite devenu très
populaire dans certaines régions et
touche aujourd'hui toutes les couches
sociales
bourdieu remarque toutefois que la
pratique de ce sport n'est pas anodine
socialement et que des différenciations
sont visibles et classes dominantes sont
plus attirés par le jeu des trois-quarts
ses joueurs évitent les contacts par
leur aisance et leur style le jeu
rugueux des avants qui vous gratter les
ballons par leur courage leur impact
physique et plus conformes aux attentes
des classes populaires qui cherche avant
tout à se défouler et a évacué un
excédent de la plupart la pratique du
sport dans les chapitres suivants
bourdieu nous offre un travail d'orfèvre
en nous donnant les clés pour comprendre
l'habitus de chaque classe sociale je
consacrerai les prochains épisodes de
cette série à chacun de ses habitudes de
classe cette vidéo est finie n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner afin de ne pas rater
la suite de cette série consacrée à la
distinction de pierre boulle
je vous remercie de votre attention et
je vous dis à très bientôt sur la
société
[Musique]